it looks like a wild dragon fire
show a campaign finale in character with
caved M the presidential front runner
who wants to demolish Argentina's
political
class get rid of them all we don't want
any left the ultra conservative
Economist Wheels a chainsaw to cut
government spending and $100 bills
symbolizing he'll dollarize an economy
drowning in nearly one 140% inflation M
says that the Argentine currency the
Bessel is worth quote less than
excrement in a country that is no
stranger to eccentrics in politics M's
extraordinary rise in popularity can
only be explained by the disenchantment
that argentine's have been accumulating
over the last decade with traditional
politics 45% of argentines are living
below the poverty line what was once one
of the world's richest
countries Central left economy Minister
Serio Masa from the governing Paran his
party is polling in second place and
conservative Patricia bullrich in third
mle enjoys support from young voters
even though his schoolmates used to call
him a local the crazy
one m is convinced he talks to his dead
dog through a medium like in the movie
The Sixth Sense the big question is
whether any of the candidates will be
able to rescue Argentina from its
economic and social freefall Lu yum Al
jazer buenos
Sidis make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer